Bonjour! Aujourd'hui on va sortir un peu
de ma période médiévale chérie pour parler
épidémie, insurrection, barricades, censure
de la presse... on va parler des journées
des 5 et 6 juin 1832.
-Je n'ai aucune idée de ce qui va se passer...
-Pas d'inquiétude: j'étais là, au sommet
de la barricade, j'ai tout vu et je suis prêt
à témoigner.
-Bon, allons-y alors!
Pour vous expliquer le contexte si vous n'êtes
plus à jour dans vos frises chronologiques,
en 1832 nous sommes sous la monarchie de Juillet
et le roi est Louis-Philippe.
En 1830 a eu lieu une révolution appelée
les Trois Glorieuses, qui a mis fin à la
Restauration et au règne de Charles X. Cette
révolution ayant amené à la mise en place
d'un nouveau roi, Louis Philippe si vous avez
bien suivi, il existe plusieurs courants d'opposition
au pouvoir en 1832: quelques républicains,
beaucoup de déçus du pouvoir en place, et
des légitimistes: des partisans de Charles
X, l'ancien roi réfugié en Angleterre.
-1832, c'est aussi l'année où une violente
épidémie de choléra touche Paris. C'est
une pandémie qui est partie d'Inde et qui
a touché le monde entier, c'est pour ça
que ça s'appelle une pandémie, mais elle
atteint la France vers mars et fait 19 000
morts à Paris en six mois.
-Ça me rappelle une épidémie de peste,
qu'on a eu vers 14...
-Enfin bref, le climat à Paris en juin 1832
est légèrement tendu. Le 16 mai, le président
du conseil Casimir Périer, l'équivalent
de notre premier ministre, meurt du choléra.
Du fait des circonstances inhabituelles de
la mort du président du conseil, le roi ne
nomme pas de remplaçant pendant 5 mois. Il
conserve le «ministère Perier» et reprend
donc discrètement la direction du gouvernement.
Le 22 mai, 39 députés de l'opposition se
réunissent et rédigent un Compte-rendu qui
critique la politique menée par le ministère
en place.
Ils se réunissent chez l'ancien président
du Conseil, Jacques Laffitte, qui s'était
fait remplacer par Casimir Périer. Donc forcément,
ils ne le portaient pas vraiment dans son
cœur.
Dans ce Compte-rendu rédigé par les députés,
ils font la liste des promesses que le ministre
n'a pas tenues, ils accusent le gouvernement
d'avoir violé les libertés et entretenu
l'agitation dans le pays mais ne condamnent
pas la monarchie: comme je le disais plus
tôt ils étaient assez peu à être républicains,
et trouvaient que la monarchie actuelle n'avait
rien d'incompatible avec la liberté.
-Jusqu'en 1847, les républicains étaient
très peu représentés dans les institutions
politiques et dans l'opinion publique... Et
ne croyaient pas vraiment que la monarchie
de Juillet pourrait prendre fin.
-D'ailleurs au XVe siècle, nous non plus
jamais on se serait imaginé... Allez-y, continuez.
-Ce Compte-rendu constitue tout de même une
condamnation violente de la monarchie de Juillet
et fait un appel du pied à tous les citoyens
qui se sentent en manque de révolte:
-«La Restauration et la Révolution sont
en présence; la vieille lutte que nous
avions crue terminée recommence.»
-Les républicains et les légitimistes sont
au taquet et attendent le moindre petit élément
déclencheur pour passer à l'action.
Déjà, le 2 juin ont lieu les funérailles
du mathématicien Evariste Gallois, tué lors
d'un duel. 2-3000 personnes défilent dans
Paris dont des membres de la Société des
amis du peuple, qu'on retrouvera par la suite.
Il ne se passe rien mais le cortège est très
encadré par les gardes, qui craignaient une
émeute.
Et on en arrive au 5 juin 1832, où ont lieu
les funérailles du général Lamarque lui
aussi emporté par le choléra, plutôt républicain
et surtout très populaire.
A partir de là je fais une petite pause sur
les sources dont on dispose pour les 5 et
6 juin 1832: contrairement à la révolution
de 1830, ou à celle de 1848, on ne déborde
pas d'éléments sur la révolte de 1832.
Elle est rapidement considérée comme assez
négligeable, comme elle ne mène pas à grand
chose, et on en conserve des traces dans les
archives, la presse, les registres des hôpitaux
et des morgues et certains livres qui ont
repris l'événement. Les sources dont on
dispose sont surtout des messages transmis
par les différents gardes, agents de police,
ministres, qui participent à la répression
de la révolte: on a très peu de paroles
des personnes qui ont participé à l'insurrection,
construit les barricades... La parole est
au gouvernement, et aux vainqueurs.
-Et à moi.
-Et à toi... Si on veut. Au matin du 5 juin
1832 ont donc lieu les funérailles du général
Lamarque, qui en a laissé une dans le cœur
de nombreuses personnalités telles que des
généraux étrangers ou Lafayette qui prend
la parole pour lui rendre hommage. La foule
est constituée de plusieurs milliers de personnes,
dont beaucoup d'étudiants, des membres de
la société des amis du peuple, et à partir
d'11h30 elle quitte le domicile de Lamarque
pour commencer à défiler dans Paris.
Plusieurs incidents se produisent en chemin:
place Vendôme, des soldats sont insultés
car ils refusent de présenter les armes sur
le passage du général. Vers midi un soldat
est molesté car il aurait injurié Lamarque,
mais on n'est pas sûrs de ce qu'il s'est
exactement passé. Rue de Grammont c'est au
tour du duc de Fitz-James d'être pris à
parti, il aurait refusé d'enlever son chapeau
au passage du convoi donc on lui jette des
pierres et des chaises.
Donc il commence à y avoir plusieurs rapports
de police au fil de l'après-midi, et vers
16h le cortège arrive au niveau du pont d'Austerlitz.
Là on sait pas trop ce qui a déclenché
l'émeute, Lafayette aurait demandé à la
foule de se disperser sans faire d'histoires,
un étudiant aurait crié...
-1832 aura son juillet aussi!
-Voilà, faisant référence à la révolution
de Juillet...
A 17h des carabiniers sont envoyés sur place,
se prennent des jets de pierre, et c'est là
que la fusillade commence, sans qu'on sache
vraiment c'est qui qu'a commencé.
-18h à présent: on sait que plusieurs
personnes ont été tuées au pont d'Austerlitz,
et qu'un groupe d'insurgés se rend vers une
caserne pour voler des armes.
-21h: c'est le bordel dans tout le centre
de Paris, place Royale, place de la Bastille
et dans les rues du Marais où des barricades
commencent à se dresser.
Les soldats en ont déjà détruit certaines
aussi, pour cela ils forcent les riverains
à illuminer les rues. Dans les hôpitaux
et les morgues, les premières victimes commencent
à arriver.
Comme ça commence à sentir le roussi, le
roi décide de se rendre à Paris: ça peut
sembler bizarre mais pendant la révolution
de 1830, Charles X était resté bien au chaud
chez lui à Saint-Cloud et ça n'a pas vraiment
plu. Louis-Philippe préfère essayer de montrer
sa présence, il passe quelques troupes en
revue, ça fait bel effet.
-Durant la journée du 6 juin, les combats
continuent dans le centre et le Nord de Paris,
mais les gardes et soldats gagnent du terrain.
-George Sand, qui habitait dans le centre
de Paris à ce moment là et avait la malchance
de vivre près d'une morgue qui plus est,
a témoigné des événements depuis sa fenêtre
dans une lettre écrite quelques jours plus
tard.
Finalement le dernier îlot de résistance
se trouve autour du cloître Saint-Merry et
de la pointe Sainte-Eustache, qui sont repris
vers 17h30. Le 6 juin en fin d'après-midi,
les combats sont donc terminés et la victoire
revient aux soldats. Mais on n'en a pas encore
terminé avec cette histoire.
-Oooooh non.
Déjà, je tiens à signaler que les gardes
municipaux et nationaux étaient très désorganisés,
ils trouvaient pas leur point de rassemblement,
certains on fui face à nous malgré les ordres...
-Ils vous ont quand même battus.
-T'es encore là toi? Ouiii ben tout ça
c'est à cause de la propagande de toute façon.
-Je vois pas en quoi ça explique votre défaite...
-Censure de la presse, théories du complot,
c'était pas joli à voir!
-J'ai l'impression que tu cherches à changer
de sujet, mais allons-y, d'accord: durant
les 5 et 6 juin, la presse a été surveillée
de très près.
Le journal officiel, le Moniteur Universel,
a pu publier tout ce qu'il voulait. Par contre
les journaux d'opposition, comme Le National
et La Tribune sont saisis, le numéro du 6
juin est mis sous scellé, interdiction de
publier. C'est valable à Paris et dans les
autres villes de province, où la nouvelle
commence à se répandre: par exemple à
Strasbourg la presse d'opposition reste interdite
les 7 et 8 juin.
-Évidemment, le Moniteur Universel nous a
traités d'anarchistes et de bandes de Chouans
alors que le National nous appelait le peuple,
tout simplement.
-Tout cela permet d'éviter d'autres émeutes
en métropole, il n'y a que quelques troubles
qui éclatent mais ne durent pas. On informe
rapidement les autres départements et les
pays étrangers que tout est sous contrôle,
et on écrit un beau récit officiel pour
mettre fin à l'événement. Dans ces récits
on héroïse le roi, alors qu'il n'a pas fait
grand chose, et on met en valeur la prise
du cloître de Saint-Merry, la dernière barricade
à être restée debout. Elle est même qualifiée
de centre des opérations des insurgés, mais
ça c'est un peu exagéré. Par contre François
Vidocq, dont je vais pas faire la biographie
ici, aurait collaboré avec les autorités
en infiltrant les barricades, et en fournissant
quelques uns de ses agents... Mais c'est pas
quelqu'un de très fréquentable alors on
ne parle pas de lui dans les récits officiels.
-On ne parle pas non plus de la prise de la
mairie du VIIIe arrondissement, où on a pu
rentrer comme dans un moulin.
-Ben non, la parole n'est pas vraiment aux
insurgés survivants.
-Mais c'était qui ces insurgés au final?
-Remarquable transition, qui étaient-ils?
Comme je vous le disait, on a très peu de
témoignages d'eux. Dans les jours qui suivent
l'insurrection on accuse les légitimistes,
ceux qui veulent remettre Charles X sur le
trône, les républicains ou même un coup
monté de la police! J'aime les théories
du complot.
Déjà on ne sait pas vraiment combien ils
étaient: les premiers journaux parlent
de 1500, 2000 personnes, mais sans aucune
preuve. Environ 1500 personnes sont arrêtées
pendant les combats ou dans les semaines qui
suivent, et il devait y avoir au moins 300
morts, dont au moins la moitié du côté
des insurgés. C'est vague.
D'après les registres des morgues, on a une
idée générale de qui ils étaient: la
plupart était jeunes, dans les 25 ans, vivaient
dans le centre de Paris et étaient célibataires.
Ils exerçaient des métiers dans l'artisanat,
le commerce ou les services. Ceux qui ont
été tués au Nord, vers la porte Saint-Denis,
étaient un peu plus âgés et venaient souvent
de province. Et c'est tout. Il devait y avoir
aussi beaucoup d'étudiants parmi eux. La
plupart des victimes restent anonymes dans
les registres. Parmi les personnes arrêtées
à la barricade de Montmartre, il y avait
aussi quelques gardes nationaux. C'est cocasse.
-Puisqu'on parle de ça, on avait réussi
à monter environ 200 barricades! Et pas
juste des bouts de bois mis les uns au dessus
des autres, certaines formaient des complexes
sur plusieurs rues, et étaient reliées par
les boutiques et les ateliers au rez de chaussée.
-Que s'est-il passé après l'insurrection?
Dès le 6 juin, la ville de Paris est mise
en état de siège jusqu'à la fin du mois.
En mettant en place l'état de siège, on
s'assure que les personnes arrêtées seront
jugées par le conseil de guerre et non les
tribunaux habituels, les peines risquent donc
d'être plus lourdes. Cet état de siège
est très critiqué, par les républicains
qui parlent de coup d'Etat et par des avocats
qui le déclarent illégal. Il est donc levé
dès le 29 juin, ce qui est aussi vu comme
un signe de faiblesse du gouvernement de la
part de la population et des pays étrangers.
-Si vous n'arrivez pas à assurer l'ordre,
on critique. Si vous êtes trop autoritaires?
On CRITIQUE.
-Dans les semaines qui suivent l'insurrection
des personnes sont arrêtées, des journaux
sont poursuivis, ainsi que certaines associations,
on demande aux médecins dans les hôpitaux
de dénoncer les blessés qu'ils ont soigné...
Mais finalement la tension se relâche assez
vite.
Les deux premiers procès, qui ont lieu devant
le conseil de guerre, mènent à des acquittements.
Ensuite comme l'état de siège est levé
on revient à une justice normale et la plupart
des accusés sont condamnés à des peines
de travaux forcés ou de détention. Au total
261 personnes sont jugées, sur les quelques
1500 arrestations. Certains groupes sont totalement
blanchis comme les 216 étudiants de polytechnique
qui avaient été arrêtés, et on relâche
la surveillance des blessés qui étaient
encore à l'hôpital. En quelques semaines,
l'insurrection commence déjà à passer dans
l'oubli et on n'en parle presque plus dans
les journaux.
Du côté des vainqueurs, les policiers et
gardes blessés durant l'insurrection, environ
240 personnes, reçoivent 50 000 francs par
l’État.
L'insurrection des 5 et 6 juin 1832 semble
donc tomber dans l'oubli rapidement, et n'être
qu'une répétition ratée de ce qui se passe
ensuite, en 1848.
Et pourtant, elle est restée dans l'Histoire,
en grande partie grâce à un auteur: Victor
Hugo.
Avant lui, il y a eu deux tentatives de romans
reprenant l'insurrection de 1832: Le Cloître
de Saint-Méry, de Marius Rey-Dussueil, et
L'aurore d'un beau jour de Noël parfaits.
Les deux livres sortent dans la foulée des
événements, respectivement fin 1832 et en
1833. Ils sont tous deux interdits, brûlés
en 1833, et Noël Parfait est condamné à
deux ans de prison et 500 francs d'amende.
Les Misérables paraissent en 1862. Trente
ans après, et pourtant Victor Hugo a hésité
à publier cette histoire par peur de la censure,
étant donné qu'une partie de son roman est
basée sur l'insurrection.
Il avait déjà raconté les événements
au moment où ils s'étaient produits, puisque
comme George Sand il en avait été témoin.
En 1832 il en dit ceci: «Émeute du convoi
de Lamarque. Folies noyées dans le sang.
Nous aurons un jour une république, et, quand
elle viendra d’elle même, elle sera bonne.
Mais ne cueillons pas en mai le fruit qui
ne sera mûr qu’en juillet; sachons attendre.
La république proclamée par la France en
Europe, ce sera la couronne de nos cheveux
blancs. Mais il ne faut pas souffrir que des
goujats barbouillent de rouge notre drapeau.»
-Est-ce qu'il vient de me traiter de goujat?
-J'aime cet homme.
-En 1832, les insurgés sont des goujats pour
lui; trente ans plus tard, il en fait des
héros. Entre-temps il est devenu républicain,
et a compris que les classes les plus pauvres
de la société n'étaient pas à prendre
à la légère.
Dans Les Misérables, il ne fait pas le récit
de 1832. En tout cas, pas un récit fidèle.
Pourtant il était là, il a un souvenir de
ce qui s'est passé et où, mais ce n'est
pas le but de son histoire. Il prend des événements
avérés, quelques noms de personnes et de
rues retrouvés dans les archives, mais y
mêle déjà sa propre fiction, avec les personnages
qu'il a inventés...
-Gavroche.
-Il ajoute aussi des éléments des révolutions
de 1830, 1848... Et même des références
à la bataille des Thermopyles: dans les
Misérables il glorifie l'insurrection de
1832, mais surtout l'insurrection en elle-même,
et on peut lui reconnaître d'avoir su glisser
une insurrection oubliée, trente ans après,
dans un roman qui a largement traversé les
siècles depuis.
-Il en a traversé deux.
-On s'en fiche! C'est super bien écrit!
-Ainsi donc se termine l'histoire de l'insurrection
des 5 et 6 juin 1832, j'espère qu'elle vous
a plu.
Je profite de cette fin de vidéo pour vous
annoncer que je lance un compte tippeee, pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas c'est un site
de financement participatif où vous pouvez
donner des sous si vous souhaitez participer
au financement de ce que je fais sur youtube.
Le lien est dans la description et sur ma
page tippeee vous retrouverez toutes les explications
possibles et imaginables.
Voilà, je vous souhaite de bonnes fêtes
de fin d'année et à
la prochaine!